lay dying
he breathed deeply of the fresh sea
breeze tinged with a fog
that cooled his burning head and thought
back
to his youth he had devoted the best
years of his life
to the holy church's mission in his
homeland of japan
more and more however he had felt tested
and been filled with doubt
he tried to fight it remember the glory
of rome
but his faith could not stand against
the rejection of the foreign priests
passed over for ordination one too many
times
so different from in europe itself the
beating heart of christianity
where they had been treated as princes
leaping their strange dances
taking in the ornate palaces and stone
castles and enjoying seats of honor
in the continent's greatest houses of
god
he had finally given up his christian
faith and name
miguel to return to the life of a
samurai in his cousin lord omora's court
and over the years as christianity had
been brutally swept
from the country his friends had
suffered death
persecution and exile he knew
he had made the right choice seen the
false guard for what it was
but now as chijua awaited the next life
he'd asked his youngest son to search
out his hidden rosary beads
one last souvenir of the years when he
and his companions
had accomplished one of the most
astonishing journeys
in history a round trip
to rome taking eight whole
wonder filled years the first
japanese embassy to europe
jiji was side laid his head on the
wooden pillow
and remembered
this video is sponsored by magellan tv
the documentary streaming service
thanks to everyone that signed up to the
new channel it's not only that that's
coming this year
lots of exciting projects on the horizon
including a feature-length deep dive
into the time and place that really
started this channel
ancient china and these new projects
have been possible because of some great
support from magellan tv
their documentary service provides great
context for our videos
and this month i'd like to recommend the
first emperor
the man who made china a fascinating
exploration of one of history's most
important people this is just one
example of the more than 3
000 documentaries magellan offers and
now you can take advantage of an
exclusive offer
30 off an annual membership this gives
you an entire year for less than 3.50 a
month
even if you've joined magellan before
and lapsed you can simply click on the
link in the description to claim your
discounted membership today
thanks
you ask dear brothers about the reason
for our expedition
the first reason that father alessandro
valenyano visitor of the society of
jesus
judged it expedient after he arrived in
japan
he learned by experience that the
customs of japan are in many ways very
different
from those of europe he also realized
that because of the vast distance
between the two
the scale and magnificence of provinces
and kingdoms in europe the majesty
and power of their leading men and many
other admirable things
had reached the islands of japan only as
a sort of
distant rumor this had many unfortunate
results
to the detriment of souls
alessandro valenyano visitor of the
society of jesus to the indies
knelt caesar in the ornate golden
chamber high atop
azuchi castle mount his legs were numb
but he hardly noticed at such a height
with a shimmering lake biwer spread out
before him
it almost felt like he was in heaven if
valenyano had not been convinced of the
truth of jesus and his sacrifice for
mankind he might easily have thought
that the man who sat before him
the creator of this earthly paradise oda
nobunaga
japan's most powerful warlord was
himself
divine he could never adequately
describe the paradise-like
sophistication of japan's palaces in his
reports to rome
he knew they doubted such a world was
possible so far from europe
would never fund this mission the way it
deserved
the japanese for their part for all the
globes spectacles glass
guns armor and fine clothing that the
jesuits gifted them
still called the europeans barbarians
however far the jesuits went they could
never truly show the grace
and sophistication of christendom and
therefore the rightness
of god's presence in the country
valenyano had come to realize one thing
in japan
had he not seen it with his own eyes he
would never have understood or even
believed in its splendor
conversely jesuit tales of european
wonders and the truth of christ
must seem little better than barbarian
fairy tales to the japanese
he wishes he could take nobunaga to rome
and bring the pope here to japan
the italian missionary returned to matas
at hand
nobunaga was inviting him to view two
magnificent screens depicting the castle
explaining that the emperor himself
asked for them to adorn his palace
but these were a gift for rome nobunaga
explained
to show the european pope the glory and
power of japan as valenyanu observed the
wondrous screens
something like divine inspiration came
to him
these should be presented not by him
but by young japanese noblemen
they could both demonstrate their
intelligence culture and grace
and subsequently report back to japan on
europe's
magnificence the boys would have to be
carefully chaperoned of course there
were
unsavory aspects of christendom that
were best glossed over
but the more he thought about it the
more he was convinced
that he could lead a legation of
ambassadors
to present these gifts the first ever
from one eternal city
kyoto to the other
rome
so it was that nagasaki on the 20th of
february of the year 1582
with god as our leader and the father
visitor as
so to speak the standard bearer for our
coming battle with the ocean and the
waves
we joyfully boarded the ship of the
portuguese nobleman
ignacio de lima
over the next nine months preparations
were hastily made for a delegation of
four young nobles from three converted
catholic domains
to make the long dangerous and arduous
journey
to europe and back ito mancio
born catholic and kinsmen to lord ottomo
sauron of bungo domain
was to lead as his lord was one of the
most powerful daimyo on the national
stage
chijiwa miguel nephew of lord omora
sumitada
and second cousin of lord arima harunobu
was to jointly represent the two small
but solidly catholic domains
he had been baptized only two years
before departure
haramatino and nakawa huliao both from
christian samurai families of the omura
domain
were deputies should anything untoward
happen to the two leggetts themselves
the oldest was only 14.
they set sail from nagasaki a jesuit
governed port
on february the 20th 1581
given the importance of his passengers
the captain gave them his own cabin for
the three weeks to macau
during the voyage as the crew toiled
ceaselessly around them
they concentrated on their studies latin
from diogo de mesquita the chaperone
and japanese with giorgio loyola a
japanese jesuit
who had been appointed to ensure they
did not neglect their mother tongue
it took a full 10 months in southern
china for favorable wins to present
themselves
but the boys eventually arrived in
malacca after 28 days sailing
this time the winds blew and after only
a week they were off to india
despite a brush with pirates near wrecks
semi-starvation foul water the death of
much of the crew from disease
and a six-month stopover in kochin they
arrived in goa
capital of portuguese india in november
1583.
16th century travel was a fickle affair
in goa they were received by their first
european dignitary
the viceroy of india they also received
a huge shock
valenyano had been appointed superior of
the asian church
and despite his huge disappointment and
the boy's dismay
he would be forced to remain there they
would have to continue without
their mentor guide the next stop was
saint helena a speck of an island in the
south atlantic
later to pay host in napoleon in his
final and fatal exile
crossing the equator the boys must have
exclaimed in wonder
as the stars flipped on their heads
they were now preparing in earnest for
their journey's goal
and practice the european musical
instruments and flowery latin oratory
which was to so impress the nobles of
catholic europe
more often than not however the seas
heaved
and the boys lay in bed faces pale
stomachs queasy
on the 10th of august we reached the
port of lisbon the flood of joy we
experienced as we entered that port is
almost beyond the power of words to
express
because it was the end at last of the
troubles and difficulties
and because we could now feast our eyes
on an amazing range of new things
ito and his companions hid in the
captain's cabin while the ship was
unloaded around them
their arrival was to be kept quiet to
avoid exciting the population
the boys were shattered after two and a
half years of travel
but this was their moment this was what
they had traveled so far for
they would finally set foot on the
continent
of rome of the pope a step made by less
than a handful of their fellow
countrymen
ever before disembarking by night
they were road softly to a sleeping
lisbon
the stench of the city struck them long
before they reached land
it was high summer there was no sewage
system
but it was a grand city built on the
profits of trade
slaves from africa spices from india
silk from china
and silver from japan the boys
dived right in eyes flitting everywhere
absorbing every
astonishing detail
the legates were immediately granted the
use of the viceroy cardinal albert's
personal carriage four flawless white
horses conveyed them around lisbon
taking in noble houses churches convents
monasteries hovels
shops plazas fortifications docks and
schools
wondering at how much more comfortable
and indeed stylish the coach was
compared to the palanquins the japanese
nobles traveled in
this is the king's fountain announced
the driver handito pressed his face to
the glass window
the most novel thing are known of in
japan were blinds and shutters served
instead
multi-storied buildings with ornate
arches and red roofs
towered above and around the fountain
semi-veiled women lugged water
men gossiped porters held great loads on
their heads
children ran workers heaved beggars
begged servants attended their employers
thieves thieved jugglers juggled and
animals
cried knights rode fine arabian horses
so much nobler somehow more ladylike can
refined than the hardy muscular ponies
they knew from home
the poorest went barefoot some were
barely clothed at all
the crowd was very much like the other
portuguese cities they had seen around
the world
but now there were many more african and
european faces
a monkey escaped his tamer slipping
through the open window to investigate
his audience
no tail everything truly seemed to be
other
a pole apart from what they knew
the coachman gave a touch of his whip
and the carriage moved on several more
churches in the royal hospital awaited
them that day
by the end of their stay they had graced
almost all of lisbon's
130 churches seven hospitals
six royal palaces and dozens of noble
homes besides
it was a thrilling but whirlwind first
view of the continent valignano had
promised them
finally cardinal albert had nobunaga's
screens carefully unpacked for a private
viewing jujiwa had not seen them before
and he gasped truly it was a castle
worthy of a great ruler
though he felt anxious as the portuguese
handled their two and a half year cargo
the cardinal likewise was thrilled to
see an image of the great castle
they had imagined that they would be
approaching europe that knew nothing of
and was perhaps
indifferent to their homeland but their
host had read jesuit reports avidly
and seemed to know more of japanese
politics than the young men
themselves gigiwa stretched his aching
limbs
the long journey on dusty bumpy roads
little more than tracks
was much eased by the loan of another
carriage and cardinal albert's parting
gift
300 crowns but the journey to madrid
was still a struggle they would be
received by albert's uncle
his most catholic majesty king philip ii
of spain and first of portugal
the most powerful ruler in europe if not
the world
as he stretched chijua recited the words
of his greeting
from the liege in japan again and again
and again with the lord's grace
i write to your royal majesty
this was the first task he had been
charged with
he could not fail
it can be said without fear of incurring
odium or giving offence to anyone
that king philip has extended the
jurisdiction of his kingdom
further and wider than any of the other
european kings
america is whole and entire under his
jurisdiction
and that includes the extremely rich
countries of peru
and mexico and brazil thus almost the
entire navigation of the ocean is
subject
to him ito and chijua
led the way dignified and glowing in
their white silken japanese robes
soldiers beat their way through the
throngs of citizens eagerly clamoring to
get a look at the visitors from afar
through the twelve halls of the royal
alcazar of madrid
they marched as the door opened on the
inner sanctum
the king his son and two daughters oh so
tall and clad in magnificent red gowns
sewn with pearls and golden thread
stood awaiting their arrival it went
against all the boy's instincts to stay
standing in front of such a monarch and
his family
in japan they would have kept their
faces to the floor in a zaray bow
not even raising their eyes but here ito
did as valinano had trained them
he walked slowly forward bowing low from
the waist
to kiss the royal hand
but the royal hand was not there
ito dared to raise his eyes suddenly the
ambassador felt lips on his cheek
bony arms stretched around him ito
fought his instincts to flinch to shrink
within the warm embrace
he had never been hugged before let
alone by the ruler of half the world
with an effort he forced himself to
relax smile
to show appreciation for this great
accolade
the long-anticipated ceremony descended
into casual conversation
as the king asked about every aspect of
the visitors attire
their health and their country finally
it was time to attend to ceremony
ito representing lord ottomo of bongo
his mouth dry
with nerves spoke first
with the lord's grace i write to your
royal majesty through the fathers of the
society of jesus who teach the true
doctrine in these kingdoms
i have often heard of your majesty's
affairs and your kingdoms
because of navigation problems and the
long route i have not yet communicated
with your majesty
i send my cousin lord mancio of hugo i
beg your majesty that you may deign to
favor him in everything
and also the japanese church and
myself from now on
then followed his incessant practice
paying off and all present
wandered the japanese boys unexpectedly
elegant
oration
the day came to a close with vespers in
the royal chapel
candles glowed the sweet voices of the
choir gave praise to heaven
and the organs great rumble embraced the
chamber
as the boys knelt praying in the front
pews a true understanding of the power
and magic
of the alien religion began to grow
within their hearts
to arrive in madrid they had ridden
through the forested mountains and
across
the arid plains of iberia lodged in
palaces monasteries and manners
choirs and musicians had serenaded them
over dinner school boys treated them to
speeches recitals dances and plays
the duke of magantha's mother katharina
had been so charmed by their japanese
costume
that she had had her tailors work
through the night to get up a kimono to
dress her son in
the next day the japanese boys had
giggled straightened his costume
and finally thrust a sword into his belt
ito had solemnly stated you
are now a japanese lord my lord
the night after meeting king philip
ito's brain would not rest
the most powerful man in the world's
embrace that day seemed symbolic of
europe
her god and her people embracing him his
legation
and a christian japan he knew he must
return home and bring word of all of
this
these were not the barbarians that his
countrymen knew they were civilized
warm-hearted powerful
glorious and cultured as he tried to
take it in
overwhelmed he slowly drifted to sleep
more audiences with spanish nobility
followed a visit to the king's
magnificent new palace at escoriel
and his menagerie where they saw an
elephant and rhinoceros
the boys dazzled their hosts with
demonstration of samurai swordsmanship
calligraphy their newfound
accomplishments in european arts
and answers to endless probing questions
about their homeland
it was bewildering exhausting but
somehow
ito and his comrades took it in their
stride
they were now being openly viewed and
referred to as magi
the kings of christ's birth story former
pagan christians from the end of the
earth following the star of european
civilization
to pay homage to the universal church
and adore the one god and his son
in reformation europe divided and at
bitter and bloody war with itself
this was a huge victory for catholicism
and a public kick in the face
for protestants in the cold northern
reaches of christendom
who had so recently turned away from
rome and the embrace
of mother church the heretics were not
to be graced with the gations from
civilized oriental lands
the witch queen elizabeth of the english
who for catholics symbolized pure evil
did not enjoy the right to homage from
distant realms
for catholic europe the legation from
japan
proved the glory of spain
and of rome and her church
and after a glorious month in madrid it
was time to leave the acclaimed magi to
continue their pilgrimage
to the center of the catholic world the
eternal city rome
the final approach to rome took four
months
along with the usual rounds of
cathedrals masses and serenades
they survived a coach crash enjoyed near
brushes with pirates who had heard of
the rich gifts they carried
and escaped bandits in the wild italian
countryside
the most illustrious princess had many
most noble young girls pressing around
her
all were delighted with that gathering
what with the sweetness of the singing
and harmony
with the very talk on this side and that
and with their pleasure
in seeing the japanese clothes nakora
his heart pounding thought quickly they
were the grand
ball held in their honor by bianca
capello the duke of tuscany's wife
the ladies young and old were dressed
with the utmost elegance
their beauty enhanced all the more by
the cosmetician's art
the tens of thousands of candles in the
great chambers chandeliers were
reflected in the precious stones that
adorned their persons
and lent a shimmering ambience to the
night's festivities
just the kind of thing to set a 16 year
old's pulse
racing the hostess had chosen ito for
her partner in the dance line
to which he had hesitantly accepted and
then chosen another lady in turn
chijuan hara had been chosen and then
summoned their ladies to the dance floor
nakaura's face reddened he moved timidly
out into the open space
and almost without thinking picked out
the first lady who met his gaze
too late he realized she was elderly
elegant smooth-faced but silver-haired
the lady burst out laughing so did the
rest of the guests but nakaura persisted
he cannot fathom where to put his feet
so different from the no
dances he had watched as a child in his
father's rural thief
he cringed when he remembered but pisa
would never forget his gallantry
whoever has not seen rome confesses that
he has been deprived of the most
pleasing of sights
oh for a new river and rich flow of
language to add to my poor
and almost exhausted powers of speech so
that in the presence of such majesty
all that i have already said about other
cities could be considered insignificant
and inferior the glowing torches of the
soldiers flickered in the night
as the legation entered the eternal city
it was now three years since they had
bid farewell
to their homeland the romans were out in
force
woken from their slumbers by the
fanfares of the escort that pope gregory
had sent to convey his japanese guests
the last few miles the goal
of their incredible globe trotting
odyssey
ito gaped chijuwa stared hara looked on
pensively already composing his diary
entry for that night
but nakaora slipped in and out of
consciousness
wrapped tight in a blanket his head
burning up only one thought pierced his
building fever
could he fulfill his mission or would he
die on the very brink
the coach inched forwards to joyful
cheers people craning their necks to spy
the exotic ambassadors
the heralded magi of the east had
arrived
pope gregory had been waiting for this
moment holding on to his fading life
force
willing the japanese ambassador's god
speed through the italian countryside
to see him before he went to meet his
maker
now he could hear the canon outside
saluting their arrival
and they were finally here his heart
raced
filled with elation
the door opened at the end of the wide
salaragia audience hall
and the three japanese noblemen made
their way slowly towards him
the old pope's face lit up
a welcome noble strangers from afar
the three oriental knights approached in
turn gregory stood and held out his hand
as each legget completed his homage the
pope embraced them with a kiss
on the cheek gregory's soul
filled with joy he could now die
happy the cursed heretics who he had
spent his life fighting who threatened
to destroy his
church could be repulsed with the
strength furnished by these new souls
brought to christ's love for these were
not just three boys
they were representatives of one of the
world's biggest realms
all the maps agreed japan was larger
than india bigger than arabia
rivaling even the catholic domains of
western europe for size
here in his presence was the future of
christ's mission on earth
a new frontier for the one true
church
ito and chijua hearts pounding with
humility and awe
gave their speeches of humble allegiance
and veneration to the pope
in japanese then stood to listen as an
italian translation was read out
the jesuit gaspar gonzalez then gave an
eloquent address in latin
praising the japanese islands and people
gonsav's assertion that just as the
british isles had been converted under
pope gregory the great now japan was to
enter christ's fold under this pope
gregory
moved the audience to tears but meant
little
to the boys ito reminded himself to ask
what this meant later
finally the pope indicated to the boys
that they should carry the train of his
robes as he departed the chamber
an extreme honor awarded only to the
ambassadors of great empires
lords ottomo amura and arima ito and
chijua's masters
ruled over territories collectively
about the same size
as the island of cyprus
a whirlwind of honours and invitations
followed diplomats whined and dined them
representatives of the senate
accompanied by 24 elictors made a solemn
visit to inform them that they were to
be appointed
roman citizens and patricians gregory
summoned them again and again
gifting them sumptuous robes quizzing
them about every aspect of their
homeland
and plotting the future of the japanese
church
pope gregory viii passed away at the age
of 84.
only 18 days after first welcoming the
japanese boys
they had not even known he was ill on
his deathbed
saint peter's heir remembered to ask
after the health
of his four visitors
white smoke drifted slowly above the
sistine chapel
a new pope had been chosen
sixtus v had no doubt who would be pride
of place at his investiture
just as the old pope had symbolically
had japan carry his train
so he would have them bear the canopy
which screened him during the coronation
mass
the robes of state were heavy but this
strongest world of popes bore them
lightly
he came not to bring peace but a sword
of justice
to sweep away the ills that tore
christendom apart
in the rebellious british isles he would
again excommunicate the heretic
queen urging her subjects to rise up for
christ
just as these boys would wield their
finely wrought scimitars on the islands
at the other end of the world
as ito washed the new pope's hands
during the ceremony
sixtus looked down and permitted a small
smile
to creep across his otherwise serene
visage
a final honour awaited the legates from
japan
in rome the boys knew what was coming
they had been coached in the protocol
for the thousandth time in the past year
their hearts beat strong within their
breast and emotion
threatened to overwhelm them they
received the golden swords kneeling
and in turn offered them up to the pope
his holiness
tapped the shoulder of each youth three
times
kissed their young faces tenderly draped
golden chains around their necks and
presented
four pairs of golden spurs the four
samurai
were now knights of the golden spur
nobles at both ends of the earth
their odyssey home was even longer than
their pilgrimage to rome had been
through assisi bologna venice milan
genoa barcelona madrid lisbon mozambique
goa and macau they travelled
held in honor by all final audiences
with king philip and the viceroy of
portugal left the maladen down with
presents
and funds for the japanese mission the
journey back to nagasaki accompanied by
valignano once more
took four long years
in their wake they left europe tingling
with excitement
not only in the cities that have been
graced with their presence but
everywhere
there were at least 76 works published
in italian spanish portuguese latin
french and
german letters and publications reached
places as far away as prague and krakow
queen elizabeth was not amused
valenyano's brainwave in azuchi castle
had truly set the world alight
but there was one more goal of this
globe-spanning mission
to tell japan about europe
that great task still lay ahead
they arrived back on the 21st of july
1590 to
japan vastly changed from the one they
had left
nobunaga was no more and the country so
long at war with itself seemed to have
achieved a solid peace under the new
imperial regent toyotomi hideyoshi
but whereas nobunaga had been positively
disposed towards the mission due to its
material benefits
hideyoshi was more of an enigma
in 1587 having been disgusted by the
missionaries facilitation of japanese
slavery
their slaughter of animals for meat
disrespect for japanese beliefs and
concerned by their
general attitude he'd even gone so far
is to issue an expulsion edict
it was not enforced but the valinano was
forced to return
to clean up the mess
and so valinano became both the brains
behind the first japanese embassy to
europe
and the first european diplomatic
mission to japan
accompanying him with the four
ambassadors
they had left as boys and returned
as men on landing their families didn't
even recognize them
valinano presented his diplomatic
credentials through intermediaries
and while awaiting an audience the four
boys regaled their compatriots
with tales of their travels displaying
maps artworks and all manner of exotica
they had returned with
valenyano could not have been happier
for the first time
the japanese were hearing of europe from
their own people
permission for an audience with
hideyoshi
eventually arrived
ito took a small morsel of food with his
chopsticks and raised it to his mouth
the banquet was vast and lavish but as
hideo she had already left the chamber
it was awkward to partake fully everyone
else must have felt likewise as they all
ate and drank sparingly
ito used the silence to reflect on this
awe-inspiring jurakudai palace
it was vast far more than the eye could
take in
and he reflected so different from the
palaces of europe
so much more spacious less cluttered
but also less imposing where it was
alike
was in power immense quantities of gold
silver and great artwork symbolizing the
greatness and permanence of the toyotomi
clan were everywhere
ito remember the scoria so different
from
yet so similar to this awesome edifice
suddenly hideyoshi re-entered the
chamber
everyone immediately crashed their heads
to the floor not daring to look up
but the imperial regent ordered them at
ease
and chatted informally just as king
philip pope gregory and a hundred other
european rulers had quizzed them about
japan
now hideyoshi plied them for information
about christendom and
demanded the performance of european
music with fingers trembling
the boys went through their
well-practiced routine ending it
speedily
they were unsure how it would be
received luckily
hideyoshi found the music pleasant he
said it reminded him of the shanties of
boatmen
and gang chants of workers he stroked
the instruments
surprised at their odd shapes and
ingenious
design three encores were demanded
then demonstrations of the weapons the
clock and the tent
the culmination of the enterprise had
gone as magnificently as could have been
hoped for
it was now over had it all been a dream
but the joy was not to last
hideyoshi issued another anti-catholic
edict in 1597
and this time backed it with
crucifixions
the jesuits who now included the four
boys
laid low after tokugawa isu usurped the
reigns of power following hideyoshi's
death
the jesuits became more confident only
to be definitively expelled in 1614
following english reports of alleged
jesuit attempts at regicide
against rulers who defied them the
english had finally got their revenge
for being upstaged all those years
before
one merchant even reported a meeting
with chijua
a sorry looking fellow he wrote
as far as the japanese government were
now concerned the catholics
were criminals to be reformed and if
they refused to mend their ways
be persuaded of the illegality of their
acts with the full force
of the law torture and death if needs be
the hunt for and persecution of
criminals was a highly refined art in
tokugawa japan
and within a few decades the foreign
teachings had been rooted out
ito died of sickness in 1612 hara fled
to macau in 1614
and nakaora went underground to tend
illegal hidden congregations
apostatized
smiled weakly at the thought of a world
he had known
despite the horrors that had followed
what an adventure
europe had been no one would ever have
another like it
he grasped his beads with narred hands
and a daunting thought overcame him
what if he had been wrong what if the
christ child and maria were awaiting him
on the other side
he started whispering in japanese
ave maria megumi
takata then his long forgotten latin
suddenly returned to him in death
ave maria gratia planner
dominus tecum benedicta
tu in mugliaribos benedictos
fructus
passed away before his final amen
it was january the 23rd 1633
nakaora was caught and executed later
that year he lasted four days in the
torture pit
his final words were i am nakaora
who went to rome i accept this great
suffering
for the love of god he was made a saint
in 2008. the next japanese embassy to
europe
would not be until 1862.
you